grande illusion la lévitation le plus
grand rêve de l'homme
nous allons réaliser une expérience
exceptionnelle que les astronautes de la
nasa ont confectionné pendant plusieurs
années nous avons les secrets nous
allons l'appliquer
j'aimerais devenir australiens mais j'ai
hâte légère qu'une pub un peu peur oui
un petit peu
ayez confiance avec moi oui vous jamais
avoir l'accord suivez moi vous allez
vous installer sur cette magnifique
table à l'esa installez vous souciez pas
tes pieds vous allez vous tourner
lentement vers moi j'espérais bien
uniquement professionnel car sommes
d'accord bien sûr je vais tenter de
faire disparaître la gravité de votre
corps détendez-vous un maximum
fermez les yeux franchement fermer les
yeux allez-y je vais couvrir un tissu
pour vous protéger
lever les mains d'accord
vous allez vivre une expérience
physiquement et émotionnellement très
intense mais je suis là avec vous
donc pas de panique vous permettez que
je vous touche 1 1 ce n'est pas un
[Rires]
maxime
alors j'ai besoin de la concentration
tout le monde d'accord attention la
nuque
oui vous allez devenir légère comme une
plume vous n'écoutez que ma voie
d'accords passés pied attention aux
mondieux si votre corps est
inévitablement je me sens toute chose
n'ont pas tiré vers le ciel
donc rien dessous votre esprit à quitter
votre et je vous faire gauler volée mais
logiquement à partir maintenant
élite couche épaisse que les étoiles
[Applaudissements]
vous ne sentez que rien autour de vous
vous sentez légère extrêmement léger qui
dit pour revenir sur terre est ronde
sentier vos membres
le voyage va se terminer en douceur et
des jeux vous se lève la tête je voulais
fait de ce voile et mesdames messieurs
un accès plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]